о.в.
А
це програму фокусі Європа вітаємо вас
вони допомагають при нещасних випадках
гасять вогонь рятують життя санітари
пожежники лікарі швидкої допомоги але
все частіше потрапляють у біду знову і
знову при виконанні обов'язків Німеччині
замість вдячності вони наштовхуються на
агресію волонтер розповідають що хвиля
стримування насильства помітно спадає
інколи трапляється неї жертви які не
проявляють рятувальників жодної поваги
величезний тягар для помічників а
в
бою Маркус Міллер
чергують День і ніч автомобілі швидкої
допомоги вони також відчувають
недоброзичливість що вростає як вони
виходять з такими ситуаціями ми
супроводжують під час нічної зміни в
у опів на 7 вечора початок чергування на
станції швидкої допомоги тобі філер
майбутнє санітар швидкої допомоги
попереду нього та його інструктора
Маркуса Міллера 12:00 зміна
при собі
офіційно для захисту від тварин
сьогодні субота і
о.в.
а з рівнем алкоголю зростає також ризик
зловживань і
у
повідомлення по радіозв'язку перед
супермаркетом жінка втратила свідомість
більше інформації
швидкої допомоги немає в
о.в.
з
початком у візьмемо з собою додаткову
лише
пацієнтка сидить навпочіпки на землі Її
супутник хочуть прийняв наркотики для
нього все відбувається занадто повільно
тепер Дозвольте мені спочатку з нею
поговорити щоб я зміг з нею поговорити
взагалі
автомобілі
автомобіль швидкої допомоги
стратегією і
про те як швидко може загостритися
навіть рутинний випадок тобі філлер
пережив сам
півтора роки Тому викликали на вокзал
чоловік без свідомості
коли пацієнт повернувся до тями він на
них напав
під час нападу впав майже наскільки він
був близький до смерті він збагнув лише
пізніше
і тоді знову 5 тижнів поспіль невиходу
на роботу Я помітив що більше не можу
спати коли засинав перед очима знову
з'являлися ці картини а
А ти що напади частішають пов'язано з
новою позицію очікування в
у наступний виклик шість поліціянтів та
людина у стані наркотичного сп'яніння в
і на нього одягають маску
тепер Заспокойся все добре Ми хочемо
лише допомогти
перевезення до відділення невідкладної
допомоги у супроводі поліціянтів в
а
без поліції Маркус Міллер вбив пацієнтом
сам-на-сам
це зрозуміло Дуже дякую
Після зміни
у приватному житті Маркус Міллер
займається єдиноборствами Львів колеги
питають його жартома Чому він не
втручається
тому коли доводиться часто терпіти поки
не приїде поліції або справи Не дійдуть
до самооборони позаяк психологічний
бар'єр наших співробітників що дуже
високі з
а сьома година ранку кінець війни
ми на них полювали їх лаяли їм
погрожували Але 112 працює у
[музика]
з
30 років тому впала Берлінська стіна
як живуть сьогодні люди вздовж
колишнього лінії конфлікту між сходом і
заходом Цього тижня ми починаємо серію
спеціальних випадків Вона веде нас з
Польщі через Німеччину Чехію Угорщину аж
до Румунії
робітників
заводу виступили проти комуністичного
режиму на початку 1980-х років Вони вже
заснували профспілку Солідарність вона
революції усували країну Але чи змогла
вона зробити на Польщу вирішальний вплив
зустрівся з тодішніми і сьогоднішніми
героями
падіння стіни Почалося за 500 км від
Берліну у цьому Гданську Мубарак у
збудованому для зберігання торпед тоді
верб що називалася іменем Леніна
подекуди тут ще й дотепер поводяться
зварювальні роботи і чути звуку з
Корабля або розрізають на половину або
подовжують пахне морським повітрям іржею
та залізом тут європейський центр
солідарності серця ліберальної Польщі
зустрічаємося
завжди вже навіть футболках лишні
робітника версії викликом цього разу
нинішню владу Польщі на ній написано
Конституція Лех Валенса лауреат
Нобелівської премії миру і президент у
відставці керував робітниками у боротьбі
з державою робітників і
а сталася окресліть щось добре
влітку 1980 року валенси приєднався до
учасників страйку робітників норми були
занадто високими крамниці занадто
порожніми робота занадто небезпечною
однак мова йшла також її про закон та
свободу точно які сьогодні через 18 днів
страйку тут у цьому залі комуністичний
уряд став на коліна підписав угоду дуже
товстим олівцем всередині східного блоку
народилися перше вільна профспілка
Солідарність чисто технічно падіння
стіни було викликано нами солідарністю
але але тодішні керівники усьому світі
побачили що комунізм наближається до
свого кінця просто для змін дозрів час в
А навесні Солідарність визначали
30-річчя круглого столу що він
демократичних
перетворень
це дещо говорить про сьогоднішню Польщу
привітань від національного
консервативного уряду не було
і стояла добре Вона повністю зайнята
підтримкою таких людей як Альберт
Годлевський ми на сході Польщі там де
живуть багатодітні і парафіяни тут
населенням 2000 осіб фактично всі
обирають певну національну консервативну
партію
вона виконує свої обіцянки розповідає
нам селянин Годлевський це
2015 році за піс5і
це
означає ні ні ми помічаємо це уже В
гаманці
на благо дітей
на додаткові заняття додаткову
підготовку та відпочинок
Європейського Союзу і
а столиця Польщі Варшава Сіті й сьогодні
свого роду виставкою досягнень місто
світових концернів що зі своїми
хмарочосами до ладні усьому світі і той
хто був тут востаннє при падінні стіни
без сумніву розгубитися
Пане президенте німецьких автовиробників
китайські банки американських бізнес
консультантів можливо Польща себе
продала
відкритий світ Де кожен
може отримати все що хоче в
у об'єднана Європа для них це само собою
зрозуміло
консервативну партію
у але 30 років тому тут місті Гданську
була заснована профспілка яка викликала
ефект Доміно який камінь за каменем
закінчився падінням стіни між сходом і
заходом і
і
він присвятив себе боротьбі з мафією
Антоніо засоби мирні Вітаю організація
лібера пропонують табори відпочинку саме
там де раніше жили боса Мафії як
наприклад поблизу Неаполя відомо як
Оплот організованій злочинності
держава конфіскувала землю що колись
належали гангстером і передали їх
об'єднанню Антоніо боротьбі проти
маслівці увагу зосереджує на стійкості
це також має впливати на молодих людей
що раніше повинні зрозуміти
що деякі підлітки реально вашої бояться
французів це святе національне культурне
надбання
регіону на французькому Атлантичному
узбережжі
виготовляється
молока має виражений смак Зараз навколо
і вибухнула справжня культурна боротьба
Що дозволено додавати
конфлікт між бенефіціаром
Норманська корова вона щось особливе її
впізнаєш за окулярами так називаються
коричневі плями навколо очей коли вона є
особливим молоко яке є ідеальним для
виробництва тому молоді корови постійно
пасуться наприклад на лугах фермера
Станіслава
щоранку делав але робить коло щоб
подивитися як почуваються його корови і
о.в.
у
але ще відсутні 9 кольорів не спішіть
мало-помалу вони всі знову з'являються
але пишається своїми 130 і їхні молоком
адже його можна використовувати для сиру
який подається під захищеною державою
маркою камамбер із Нормандії і
у на пакування він спритно написав
вироблений у Нормандії стратегії щодо
якої консервує зараз не висловлюватися в
а адже проти цього виступили норманський
фермери і регіональні виробники сиру так
як традиційне підприємство в
і так діло не піде адже справжні
camembert можна виробляти лише з молока
норманських корівки і найкраще із сирого
молока в
у
молоко має тонкий баланс при бродінні
чому треба дотримуватися правил і
[музика]
як правило для отримання від держави
бажаного ярлика походження у майбутньому
може використовуватися також і
пастеризоване молоко що підходить
великому виробнику
виробники можуть жити з компромісом адже
майже половина нормандському молока має
все одно пастеризувати ся щоб
відповідати санітарному контролю в
у у Парижі столицю гурманів туристи
вважають це неможливо в
о.в.
у
абсолютно неприпустимо щоб для
виробництва камамбера можна було
використовувати тепер пастеризоване
молоко цей кінець традиції камамберу
власне для того існує щоб зберегти
традицію щоб майбутні покоління також
могли насолоджуватись камамбером і
сирого молока через 50 100 або і через
150 років з
у але нормальні не хочуть щоб їх повчав
спеціалісти з сиру з далекої столиці
вони добре домовилися адже купувати
більше молока нормандських корів і
[музика]
у собі в яке вочевидь можна укладати
майже стільки ж любові та енергії
хлопці здається що це приносить купу
задоволення Дякую вам що відкрилися наша
програма прощаємося до наступної
зустрічі Допобачення і
[музика]
о.в.